everyone it is Jessie from the tasty
team and today I'm a baking up 5
celebrity chocolate-chip cookie recipes
see which one is actually the best I'm
sorry is line up we have recipes from
Martha Stewart Snoop Dogg Kourtney
Kardashian Michelle Obama and the rock
himself we measure everything is the
recipe stated to keep things fair and we
got three of our friends to taste them
in a blind taste test
so who is the best chocolate chip cookie
recipe find out first up is Martha
Stewart she starts by combining flour
baking powder baking soda and salt and
whisk him just until combined
set that aside then in the bowl of a
stand mixer fitted with the paddle
attachment combine butter white sugar
and brown sugar and beat that until nice
and fluffy scrape that down to that add
two eggs and vanilla extract scrape that
down and slowly add your dry ingredients
half at a time just so it gets
completely incorporated and bring in an
insane amount of chocolate chips this is
4 and 1/2 cups which seems like more
chocolate than actual day forcing it out
using a scoop I'm popping in the oven
there you have it Martha's classic
chocolate chip cookies thank you our
deepest smells like chocolate chip it
looks like a chocolate chip cookie like
very classic this feels good this feels
like it should I wanted to be a little
gooey er but I like the like I like the
weight this is a weighty cookie breaks
apart really beautifully it's very um
feels under baked there's there's
chocolate and everybody firm on the
outside gooey on the inside that's
really important in a cookie but my
hands are like a little oily which I
don't really like that much it's not my
favorite I'm gonna be honest with you I
like a more crispy crispy cookie
up next is Snoop Dogg he starts by
combining flour baking soda and salt in
a bowl and mixing it up until combined
set that aside bring in another bowl and
add butter and peanut butter white sugar
brown sugar and beat that up with a hand
mixer until nice and fluffy
scrape that down and add one egg and
vanilla extract and mix it up one more
time just until combined bring back your
dry ingredients add those and slowly mix
that in fold in your chocolate chips and
scoop it into balls onto a baking sheet
uses a tablespoon so these are a bit
smaller than Martha's pop them in the
oven and there you have it Snoop Dogg's
Rolls Royce peanut butter chocolate chip
cookies this cookies a lot later than
the first one I can already feel there's
enough chocolate in here for me
this looks a very Keebler Keebler Elf
like soft batch also very soft I it's a
little under baked for my taste
I'm just gonna say that much peanut
butter this cookie has peanut butter in
it I hate peanut butter and I know
that's a strong take but it is what it
is
so I'm probably not look at this cookie
cutter hop whoo this is not a good
cookie experience this is like just
falls apart it's not a cookie this is
like a granola plop and butter it's good
it's good good not great I think I'm
like a chocolate chip cookie purist like
not my my favorite I wouldn't eat it
again but if you like peanut butter I'm
sure you'd love this next cookie next up
is a recipe by Kourtney Kardashian she
starts by combining melted coconut oil
palm sugar vanilla extract and pumpkin
puree and mix that up until smooth takes
a good bit of mixing just to get that
melted coconut oil completely
incorporated set that aside and in
another bowl combine the flour baking
soda baking powder cinnamon nutmeg and
salt and mix that all together so it's
nice and evenly distributed
bring back the wet ingredients and add
your dry to it mix in half just so it's
not too clumpy at first and then mix in
the remaining so it's nice and smooth
that add dairy free chocolate chips stir
that up and the dough is good to go roll
them into one tablespoon size balls and
place on a baking sheet the dough is a
bit greasy so my hands got a little
shiny pop them in the oven
and there's our cookies this looks like
a little nugget it's now the right time
to tell you that I'm allergic to this
whatever this is I'm allergic to it this
is like the dome peanut butter cookie I
was talking about cinnamon like I mean
this feels to me like it's it's not a
cookie like this feels like it's like a
salad trying to be a cookie there's not
a lot of chocolate but that's fine for
me right off the bat I smell cinnamon
this might be an oatmeal cookie which is
even more disturbing than the actual
shape of it these days how they it's
just weird I'm gonna try a bite wow this
is awful I don't know what's in this
cookie all scared there's this
everything that was left over that you
just put into a bowl and made cookies
out of like was that what this was you
want a cookie and like this this is not
the one who's gonna win your heart I I
feel like there's like a vegetable in
here if this is what your ideas for a
chocolate chip cookie just don't bother
like why just eat like a celery stick or
something up next is a recipe from
Michelle Obama which is actually Sasha
and Malia's godmothers recipe but it's
Michelle's favorite she starts by
combining all-purpose flour baking soda
and salt in a bowl and telling the other
side in another bowl combine two sticks
of butter with Crisco brown sugar and
granulated sugar and vanilla extract and
using a hand mixer mix that all up until
fluffy add two eggs fully mixing them in
with the hand mixer before you add the
next one scrape that down and to that
you're slowly gonna add back your dry
ingredients to create a dough little at
a time just so it doesn't get chunky to
that add chopped walnuts milk chocolate
chips
mint chocolate candies and white
chocolate chips and stir that all up
until combined
[Music]
using around a tablespoon force them
into balls and pop em in the oven I'm
nice looking normal cookie thank you oh
this looks nice see this is getting
closer to a cookie I like oh one of
these cookies this is like like
everything but the kitchen sink cookie
it has this kind of laziness it's thin
it has a crisp enos to it oh it's like
crunchy and flaky I love this is like my
ideal cookie not heavy enough oh my god
it's peppermint this has meant there's a
mint enos coming off of this one I don't
that's just me yeah too much stuff not
enough cookie there's a lot going on in
this cookie but I'm very much about it
this is a cookie for people who like
love drama
I like the cookie part I don't know why
it has a mint flavor to it which is not
what I want when I'm diving into a
chocolate chip cookie this is definitely
a holiday cookie it's crazy I want to
make this so that I can give to my
family last but not least is a recipe
from the rock he starts by combining
butter granulated sugar and brown sugar
in the bowl and using a hand mixer and
beating it all together until fluffy to
that add vanilla extract and two eggs
and beat it one more time until it's
combined scrape that down and add flour
two and a half cups of oatmeal that's
been pulverized into a flour salt baking
soda and baking powder and mix that up
until a dough forms add chocolate chips
chopped walnuts and a grated chocolate
bar and mix it up one more time until
it's combined looks a little dry but
we'll see roll them into balls and pop
them in the oven and there you have it
the rocks favorite chocolate chip
cookies Oh God it's cookies like to
perfect it looks delicious and it looks
like it's going to be a little soft in
the inside but still like crunchy which
is what I like it seems like the kind of
cookie that would be out for like a open
house on an apartment you want to live
here because this cookie lives here too
this is not what a job chip cookie looks
like this is a an abomination of
chocolate chip cookies ooh like a little
pool there
the chocolate it looks pretty well baked
nice job
Conger on the outside soft on the inside
but still like a little crunch it's okay
I was suspicions that this is healthy in
some way this is a good cookie I changed
my mind this is a good cookie I think
there's some salt it's not terrible it
has a definitely a nutty flavor this is
like a very elegant ladies cookie like I
think if you brought this to the Upper
East Side
this would crush it still tastes like a
chocolate-chip cookie
it's okay another five cookie said I
just tried I think that number five is
my favorite the reason why is because
there's a lot of textures it was a
beautiful cookie to look at and it just
tasted delicious like I said everything
kind of just melted together and it was
all like well distributed there at the
cookie like I wasn't tasting like a big
chunk of something a big chunk of
chocolate
number one was my favorite hands-down
I'm a cookie purist
that was the best one it wasn't a salad
it wasn't a real estate agent cookie it
wasn't a classy lady cookie it wasn't a
drama-filled cookie it was pure it was
doughy it was intense it was like it was
like had density it had depth that had
volume it was a it was a good cookie I
love cookies can't remember I basically
just destroyed all these cookies and
there's nothing that remains I think
number well the first one probably was
my probably the best I guess it's
presenting as a chocolate chip cookie
and delivering that we're talking about
chocolate chip cookies this one is by
definition I think closest to that
definition the rock Dwayne the rock
Johnson have you given you eyebrows and
cookies
I mean god bless her
that does not surprise me oh I'm not
surprised I'm not surprised there you
have it Martha Stewart has the best
chocolate chip cookie recipe what dress
we should retest next let us know in the
comments call me Martha I love you
you never you've never steered me wrong
Martha never
[Music]
you